par ordre du jour appelle la discussion
de la proposition de loi organique
favorisant l'implantation locale des
parlementaires présentée par monsieur
hervé marseille et plusieurs de ses
collègues à la demande du groupe union
centriste
madame le ministre mes chers collègues
en accord avec le gouvernement et la
commission et compte tenu du nombre
d'amendements déposés sur ce texte nous
pourrions achever son examen en
prolongeant notre séance au-delà de 20
heures sans avoir à suspendre s'il n'y a
pas d'opposition il en est ainsi décidé
parfait
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à hervé marseille auteur de la
proposition de loi organique
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ceux qui comme moi
appartenait déjà un autre haute
assemblée en 2013 se rappelle sans doute
les débats enflammés qu'avait suscité le
projet de loi interdisant le cumul de
fonctions exécutives locales avec un
mandat parlementaire à l'époque déjà le
sénat n'avait pas ménagé n'avait pas
hésité à s'ériger contre une réforme
dictée avant tout par la volonté de
plaire à l'opinion il était facile de
livrer à la vindicte populaire ces
cumulards que certains n'hésitez pas à
qualifier de profiteurs en creux nous
n'étions pas si loin du tous pourris
dont les gilet jaune et est si friand
force est de constater que malgré cette
réforme adoptée il ya plus de sept ans
les accusés les accusations contre les
élus et en particulier contre les
parlementaires n'ont malheureusement pas
disparu on a même franchi un seuil
supplémentaire puisqu'il n'est plus rare
que des élus soit agresser des
permanences dégradée pour ceux qui se
livrent à ce type de comportement le
non-cumul évidemment ce n'est pas encore
assez ce qu'ils veulent en réalité c'est
supprimer la démocratie représentative
au demeurant notre ancien collègue
françois rebsamen maire de dijon ressort
la vieille lune visant à faire du sénat
un bundesrat comme en allemagne non
cumul dégradation supplémentaire du
sénat formidable il faut donc ainsi se
méfier d'une inclination facile à
vouloir satisfaire ce que l'on pense
être l'opinion dominante à un moment
donné les gens seraient contre le cumul
supprimant le cumul dix et manuel valls
à leur ministre en effet plusieurs
études ont montré que nos concitoyens
étaient à titre général contre le cumul
mais quand la question portait sur leurs
propres élus ils étaient favorables à ce
que leurs mères puissent être également
parlementaires
récemment notre groupe a commandé un
sondage à l'institut ifop sur ce thème à
la question seriez vous favorable ou non
à la possibilité pour les députés et les
sénateurs de pouvoir en parallèle de
leur mandat national être maire d'une
commune de moins de 10000 habitants
mais sans le cumul des indemnités 57%
des sondés répondaient favorablement
ce résultat peut surprendre il a au
moins un mérite ils montrent que ceux
sur ce sujet il y a encore des bas et
pas simplement chez les élus la
proposition de loi organique j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter à d'abord
courant d'objets de faire vivre ce débat
devant le parlement il est naturel
plusieurs années après l'entrée en
vigueur d'une réforme de s'interroger
sur sa pertinence et ses conséquences
c'est la question que l'on doit se poser
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues le
non-cumul at-il améliorer le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
cette question est légitime semble-t-il
le président de la république lui-même
reconnaissait il y a plus il ya peu que
le sujet méritait d'être débattue on
constate d'ailleurs à travers les
résultats des dernières élections
locales que l'existence du non-cumul n'a
pas ramené pour autant aux urnes
beaucoup d'électeurs en revanche on
continue inlassablement de déplorer des
élus déconnecté des parlementaires hors
sol nous considérons le fait que
l'instauration du non cumul loin d'être
une solution magique a sans doute
accentuer le phénomène depuis 2014 j'ai
entendu certains de mes collègues nous
expliquer qu'avec le droit en vigueur
les parlementaires pouvaient
parfaitement continuer à détenir un
mandat local et que grâce à cela il
n'était pas déconnecté nous sommes
nombreux ici avoir été maire avoir
occupé des fonctions exécutives au sein
d'une collectivité nous savons tous que
ce n'est pas la même chose que d'être
conseiller municipal conseiller général
conseiller régional et maire président
d'un département ou d'une région en 2014
le gouvernement de l'époque justifier sa
réforme dans son exposé des motifs par
le fait je cite que la dernière révision
constitutionnelle à rénover l'exercice
de la fonction législative et renforcer
les pouvoirs des deux assemblées
autrement dit les missions du parlement
ont été tellement renforcer qu'il n'est
plus possible député et maire d'un
village de 500 habitants
avez vous le sentiment mes chers
collègues en 2021 que le rôle du
parlement soient renforcés que l'on pèse
plus sur le débat démocratique que l'
équilibre entre le pouvoir législatif et
le pouvoir exécutif est satisfaisant
pour ma part je ne le pense pas les
parlementaires n'ont pas vu leur rôle
renforcé depuis l'entrée en vigueur de
ce non cumul oui les mères qui ne sont
plus parlementaires ont souvent bien
plus de mal à faire entendre leur voix
faut-il en rester là ou revenir sur la
loi organique de 14 février 2014 plus
précisément faut-il aménager ou
l'abroger intégralement nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui un simple
aménagement
ouvrir la possibilité aux parlementaires
d'être mère au maire-adjoint d'une
commune de moins de 10000 habitants nous
avons donc choisi d'exclure cette
faculté pour les communes les plus
peuplées nous reconnaissons que la
charge de travail n'est pas la même
selon la taille de la commune il ne
s'agit pas avec notre texte d'être à
nouveau par exemple sénateur et maire
d'une grande ville de plus de 5000
habitants
inévitablement j'entends des
interrogations sur le niveau de seuil
pourquoi 10000 pourquoi pas 1000 ou
20000 comme l'a rappelé notre rapporteur
en commission ce seuil est déjà utilisé
au sein du code général des
collectivités territoriales et il nous
semblait pertinent je saisis d'ailleurs
cette occasion pour saluer le travail
important réalisé par notre collègue
stéphane leroux d'heuliez qui est
rapporteur de ce texte la tâche que lui
a confié la commission n'était pas
facile tant le sujet déchaîne des
passions je salue la qualité de son
écoute et des propositions qu'il a
formulées tout au long de ces derniers
jours une remarque sur la principale
modification adoptée en commission nous
avions souhaité éviter que ce débat
visant à favoriser l'implantation locale
des parlementaires ne soient pas
immédiatement une source de polémique
sur d'hypothétiques motivation
financière
naturellement il n'a jamais été question
d'une course aux indemnités vous savez
les uns et les autres que nous somme
plafonnée et pour couper court à toute
polémique nous avions décidé à l'article
2 de cette ppl au l'interdire tout cumul
d'indemnités pour le parlementaire qui
décideraient d'être maire d'une de moins
de 10000 habitants cela avait le mérite
de la clarté j'ai tenu à me rallier
malgré tout à l'argument
constitutionnelles défendues par notre
rapporteur et qui a entraîné la
suppression de l'article 2 en espérant
qu'il permettra d'échapper aux
polémiques inutiles enfin difficile
d'évoquer le régime des incompatibilités
applicable aux parlementaires sans
évoquer celui applicable aux élus locaux
nous avons été nombreux lors de l'examen
en commission a évoqué ce que l'on a
coutume d'appeler le cumul horizontale
la différence de traitement entre ceux
qui s'appliquent aux parlementaires d'un
côté et d'un autre côté ce qui
s'applique aux élus locaux ne disposant
pas d'un mandat national est frappante
je ne résiste pas au plaisir de vous
citer l'étude d'impact du texte de 2014
qui a indiqué à propos des fonctions
exécutives au sein des collectivités
territoriales le fait que je cite elles
représentent aujourd'hui des fonctions
de responsabilité à part entière et
suppose un engagement continu de leurs
titulaires c'est savoureux quand on
constate que cette même loi n'a pas du
tout fait évoluer les règles du cumul
horizontale permettant ainsi des
situations de cumul très étendue je
pense que les échéances politiques des
prochains mois doivent être l'occasion
d'un débat de fond sur la nécessaire
réforme de nos institutions et la
question plus abordons aujourd'hui on
fait partie vous invite donc mes chers
collègues à voter en faveur de la
présente proposition de loi organique
si notre haute assemblée devait
l'adopter j'invite d'ores et déjà le
gouvernement à l'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour de l'assemblée nationale afin de
poursuivre ce débat important
je vous en remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent monsieur stéphane rudulier
rapporteur de la commission des lois
pour 10 minutes à chaque collègue la
question de la limitation du cumul des
mandats est une question extrêmement
délicate et complexe
tous dans cet hémicycle nous sommes
d'ailleurs conscient que dès qu'une
excessifs sont aussi néfastes au
parlement qu'aux collectivités
territoriales elle-même
l'interdiction absolue d'exercer une
fonction exécutive locale
paraît aussi excessive est absurde que
la liberté absolue qui prévalait avant
le sénat a toujours été très ouvert sur
cette question il a d'ailleurs contribué
à la limitation du cumul des mandats est
ainsi voter les lois de 85 de 2000 qui
ont établi et étant dit le régime des
incompatibilités
entre mandats nationaux et mandats
locaux ces lois ont donc fait l'objet
d'un très large consensus
mais après plus d'une décennie de débats
la loi organique de février 2014 a
envoyé le balancier vers un extrême qui
s'est révélé être
mortifère pour le pouvoir législatif
elle a en effet rendu incompatibles le
mandat de député et de sénateur
avec toute fonction exécutive au sein
même d'une collectivité territoriale
plusieurs arguments étaient alors avancé
à l'appui de cette réforme il s'agissait
tout d'abord disait pan de libérer les
parlementaires de fonctions locales
devenues trop absorbante alors que le
parlement avait vu ses pouvoirs accrus
lors de la révision constitutionnelle de
symétriquement il s'agissait de lille et
les maires et les autres chefs
d'exécutifs locaux après trois décennies
de décentralisation qui avait élargi les
compétences des collectivités est
complexifiée quelque peu le rôle de
l'élu local
les promoteurs de la réforme il voyait
également le moyen d'assurer le
renouvellement du personnel politique
ces arguments
des à ce sujet à caution lors des débats
de 2013 2014
ne sont ne se sont pas vérifiées depuis
aussi aucune corrélation n'a jamais pu
être empiriquement établi entre le non
cumul des mandats et la qualité du
travail parlementaire de même
le fort taux de renouvellement de
l'assemblée nationale observée en 2010 7
me semble davantage lié à l'émergence
d'un nouveau mouvement politique
devenues majoritaires dans le sillage de
l'élection présidentielle car
l'application de la règle du non cumul
al'inverse
les faits semblent donner raison à ceux
qui craignent que les effets pervers du
non cumul des mandats ne l'emportent sur
ses effets vertueux
l'interdiction du cumul aggraverait le
déséquilibre des pouvoirs au profit de
l'exécutif nous avait-on dit en 2013 en
privant notamment les parlementaires
d'une assise locale
susceptibles de renforcer leur autorité
leur expertise et leur indépendance
faudrait-il donner raison à cette thèse
je compte y stade du moins que le
quinquennat actuel comme le précédent
d'ailleurs
n'a pas été marqué par le renforcement
du parlement tout au contraire on parle
d'affaiblissement
affaiblissement qui est contraire à la
volonté du constituant de 2008 mais ce
qui peut être un peu plus préoccupant
encore pour l'avenir c'est une
dissidence du non cumul sur
l'attractivité du mandat parlementaire
lors de l'entrée en vigueur de cette
réforme cats ont constaté qu'un bon
nombre d'élus en situation de cumul
choisissez de conserver leur mandat
local plutôt que national comme si le
premier était plus gratifiant que le
second tout cela contribue
incontestablement
à la dévalorisation du mandat de
parlementaire qui s'avère être
dangereuse pour l'équilibré de nos
institutions
enfin le fait que députés et sénateurs
ne puisse plus exercer de fonction
exécutive locale n'est pas étranger et
ça a été dit par le président marseille
au sentiment actuel de déconnexion entre
les français et leurs représentants la
connaissance des grands enjeux de la
politique nationale à travers l'exercice
d'un mandat parlementaire sont
profitables au territoire et à leurs
habitants inversement je continue de
penser que la responsabilité
opérationnelle de services publics
locaux est utile à l'exercice du mandat
parlementaire elle favorise des
approches peut-être un peu moins
idéologique - militante mais beaucoup
plus indépendante beaucoup plus
pragmatique et plus responsable
permettant de mieux saisir les attentes
des citoyens voire même parfois
d'anticiper les crises en 2019 madame la
ministre votre collègue olivier grégoire
alors député déclaré que les députés qui
avait été maire avait senti beaucoup
plus tôt ce sont ses termes arrivée la
crise des gilets jaunes
il n'est donc pas étonnant que des voix
de plus en plus nombreuses s'élèvent
pour remettre en cause la réforme de
2014 y compris au sein même de la
majorité présidentielle le président de
la république lui même s'est même
interrogé ouvertement sur l'opportunité
d'un assouplissement
lors d'une réunion avec les maires de
nos rangs en normandie le 6 janvier 2019
et le débat a ressurgi à la suite des
élections départementales et régionales
de ce printemps au vu du record de
l'abstention
j'observe enfin que trois ministres de
ce gouvernement
d'oran n'ont pas jugé nécessaire sans
doute à juste titre de s'appliquer à
eux-mêmes la règle du non cumul qui n'a
certes pas de valeur législative qui n'a
qu'une valeur coutumière en ce qui
concerne les membres de l'exécutif ils
n'ont d'ailleurs à ma connaissance
exprimer
ils n'ont d'ailleurs à ma connaissance
exprimer une quelconque contrition ou
remords à cet égard ils n'ont pas non
plus donné de signe particulier public
d'épuisement ils ont au contraire
toujours justifié cette position avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé et d'énergie
aussi force est de reconnaître que le
texte de 2014 a été mal bâti et à
procéder plus tôt à une réaction
instinctive voir quelque peu démagogique
il était donc de notre responsabilité
de trouver un dispositif plus
raisonnable de retrouver en quelques
sortes un certain équilibre c'est tout
l'objet de cette proposition de loi
organique que nous examinons aujourd'hui
initié par le président marseille et qui
vise à apporter un assouplissement
modéré à la règle du non cumul sans
revenir totalement sur la réforme de
2014 son article unique prévoit en effet
cela a été dit de supprimer
l'incompatibilité entre le mandat de
député ou de sénateur et les fonctions
de maire ou d'adjoint au maire ou maires
délégués dans les communes de 10000
habitants - soit à peu près 90 7 % des
communes françaises alors comme tout
seul le plafond de 10000 habitants peut
être discuté
néanmoins le conseil constitutionnel a
toujours admis que le législateur
organique puisse subordonner
l'application des règles
d'incompatibilité à des seuils de
population à condition que ceux ci ne
soient pas arbitraire en l'espèce le
seuil proposé par et pertinents en effet
en droit des collectivités territoriales
il correspond à une différence de
situation réelle notamment en ce qui
concerne les charges et obligations
imposées aux autorités municipales il
correspond en quelque sorte à une
frontière entre le monde urbain et le
monde rural mes chers collègues je pense
qu'une fonction exécutive locale et un
mandat parlementaire ne sont pas anti
monique ils peuvent se compléter
utilement et ce dans l'intérêt de nos
concitoyens je remercie d'ailleurs le
président marseille de son initiative je
ne doute pas qu'elle suscitera quelques
discussions parmi nous ce soir mais il
me paraît effectivement impératif de
rapprocher l'exercice du pouvoir de la
réalité des territoires et mettre fin au
sentiment que les élus nationaux sont
totalement déconnectés ce texte est un
moyen parmi tant d'autres d'y parvenir
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le rapporteur
et ministre délégué chargé de la ville
la proposition de loi organique
favorisant l'implantation locale des
parlementaires qui est présenté
aujourd'hui au sénat par le groupe union
centriste vise à instaurer la
possibilité d'un cumul entre le mandat
de parlementaire et les fonctions
exécutives de mer de maires délégués et
d'adjoint au maire dans les communes de
moins de 10000 habitants
malgré les interrogations que la
question suscite le gouvernement donnera
un avis défavorable à cette proposition
de loi et ce pour plusieurs raisons
cette proposition de loi met en
discussion le dispositif
d'incompatibilité se rattachant au mode
ans au mandat parlementaire définie à
l'article l aude 141-1 du code électoral
introduit par la loi organique du 14
février 2014 interdisant le cumul des
fonctions exécutives locales avec le
mandat de député ou de sénateur
la principale motivation de cette
proposition de loi consiste à dire qu'il
existe une attente de la part de nos
concitoyens de ne plus avoir des
représentants nationaux déconnecté du
réel ou encore des élus hors sol vous
évoquez le grand débat national engagé
dans tous les territoires par le
président de la république et il est
vrai que nos concitoyens ont exprimé un
besoin de proximité dans leurs relations
avec les autorités publiques avec les
élus et également avec les
administrations ils ont également
souligné l'importance de l'échelon
communal et de la figure du maire dans
leur quotidien est ce que nous venons de
traverser avec la crise sanitaire le
démontre parfaitement mais nos
concitoyens ont également exprimé
fortement toujours dans le cadre de ce
grand débat national
une exigence envers les élus ils ont par
exemple particulièrement critiqué les
absences des élus des séances et des
votes au sein des assemblées où ils sont
élus dès lors il ne semble pas que le
cumul des mandats soit une bonne réponse
aux besoins exprimés par nos concitoyens
nos concitoyens demandent à être ré pour
représenter tant au niveau local qu'au
niveau national par des femmes et par
des sommes pleinement engagés dans leur
mission présent là où leurs fonctions
leurs heureux qu hier pour apporter des
réponses à leurs attentes et leurs
problèmes vous évoquez aussi la
nécessité pour les élus nationaux de
disposer d'une connaissance concrète des
enjeux des difficultés et des
compétences exercées par les élus locaux
municipaux notamment le gouvernement
partage évidemment cette vision mais la
solution n'est pas nécessairement le
cumul des mandats de maire avec le
mandat de parlementaire
la loi permet déjà aux parlementaires de
conserver un ancrage local
l'article
141 du code électoral dispose en effet
qu'un parlementaire ne peut détenir
qu'un mandat parmi ceux de conseillers
régionaux de conseiller à l'assemblée de
corse de conseillers départementaux des
conseillers de paris déconseillé à
l'assemblée de guyane et de martinique
et de conseillers municipaux d'une
commune de plus de 1000 habitants les
parlementaires peuvent donc pleinement
prendre part à la vie de nos
collectivités locales s'impliquent et
par le rôle délibératif dans les
décisions prises au sein des conseils
municipaux notamment à ce titre ce sont
145 parlementaires dont 81 sénateurs qui
ont également mandat de conseiller
municipal au sein des communes de moins
de 10000 habitants
le mandat de parlementaire et la
fonction de maire demande à celles et
ceux qui les occupent d'être pleinement
disponible pour assumer ses
responsabilités depuis la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 le travail
parlementaire s'est intensifié le
travail en commissions devenue une étape
essentielle
sur lequel cela est du monde le vote en
séance requiert une implication accrue
des parlementaires le parlement s'est
aussi pleinement saisi de ses fonctions
de contrôle du gouvernement et d
évaluation des politiques un travail qui
demande également une forte
disponibilité aux parlementaires et je
peux davantage en témoigner
qu'aujourd'hui je fais partie de
l'exécutif et qu'il ya encore très peu
je faisais partie du boom va du budget
de l'assemblée nationale et donc
effectivement ce travail du contrôle du
gouvernement et de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques est très présent et
je m'en réjouis évidemment parce que
c'est le propre du fonctionnement de nos
institutions et du débat démocratique
deux députés oui
les maires des communes sont pleinement
impliqués au sein des opci dont fait
partie leur commune et donc leur
disponibilité est essentiel au bon
fonctionnement de ses institutions
au-delà de ces considérations d'autres
d'ordre technique le maire représente
dans une petite commune un point de
référence un interlocuteur du quotidien
sa présence sur son territoire est
essentiel la continuité des services
rendus par les claques la commune à ses
habitants pour gérer les petites et
grandes crises qui peuvent survenir à
tout moment pour assurer le lien
essentiel avec les services de l'état
présents sur le territoire est également
essentiel
sur le plan juridique collègues chers
collègues je pense qu'il serait agréable
c'est la ministre puisse faire son
éducation sans tout ce brouhaha je pense
que nous sommes largement regardez nous
savons que
nous savons que vous désapprouvez mais
voilà si on pollue faire dans le calme
merci beaucoup c'est en effet un merci
chers collègues ont mené avec le plus je
crois que nous en saurions tous grandis
de ce débat en tout cas sur le plan
juridique j'ai presque terminé et
ensuite on pourra évidemment échanger
sur le fond du texte sur le plan
juridique laisse le seuil de dix mille
habitants défini dans la proposition de
loi peut être questionnés dans sa
décision numéro 2000 24-6 en 89 décès du
13 février 2014 le conseil
constitutionnel a rappelé le principe
d'égalité devant la loi des règles
applicables aux interdiction du cumul
entre le mandat de parlementaire et des
fonctions exécutives locales le conseil
constitutionnel a par ailleurs admis
qu'il était loisible au législateur
d'établir et d'appliquer une règle de
non cumul à partir d'un certain seuil de
population
à condition que le seuil retenu ne soit
pas arbitraire or dans ce domaine dans
le domaine électoral le seuil de dix
mille habitants proposé dans la
proposition de loi organique est inédit
et sans lien avec une quelconque autre
disposition d'ordre électoral existantes
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
rapporteur dans vos propos la question
des cumuls des mandats est très complexe
et je me réjouis
vraiment malgré nos désaccords de ce
jour je me réjouis que nous puissions
avoir ce débat démocratique au sein de
cette haute assemblée
je vous remercie pour votre écoute la
loi de 2014 sur le non cumul
des mandats est né nous at on dit au nom
de la modernité et d'une antique
extravagance française chacun connaît le
poids des mots vous l'avez rappelé mon
cher collègue rapporteur et madame la
ministre celui de cumul est entaché de
suspicion et de culpabilité et s'est
diffusée comme un poison et un poison
pardon populistes et démagogiques
extrapolant ce qui était plutôt une
critique de l'addition des indemnités
des élus les auteurs de cette
interdiction de 2014 nous ont alors
expliqué que ce cumul était la cause de
la grave crise de confiance entre des
citoyens et leurs élus la loi nous
guérir est de tous les maux et régis
neyret la démocratie où en sommes-nous
sept ans plus tard la loi guérisseuse
n'a rien guéri eu égard à la constante
augmentation du taux d'abstention à
chaque élection la double fonction
élective serait donc une aberration en
petit comparé à d'autres pays comme
l'allemagne par exemple dire cela c'est
nier les réalités et oublier que
l'allemagne est un pays fédéral
quand la france est une république très
centralisatrice wars concentré et qu'il
est extrêmement difficile pour une
petite collectivité de freiner les
injonctions d'une administration fort
contraignant les auteurs de la loi de
2014 explique est savamment qu'il était
humainement impossible d'assumer en même
temps une fonction d'exécutif local et
une fonction élective nationale
considérant sans doute que les 35 heures
étaient la norme du temps de travail des
parlementaires
mais curieusement ces deux mêmes lois a
permis de cumuler l'exercice d'un mandat
national et d'une activité
professionnelle à plein temps et tout
aussi curieusement la possibilité d'être
maire d'une grande ville président d'une
métropole et président de nombreux
syndicats ces deux règles de 2014 était
en somme toute fort par partiale et elle
a oublié qu'une fonction d'exécutive
local s'exerce en équipe camerling
président de pc est un chef d'orchestre
qui fixe le cam et pratique la
délégation et la responsabilisation
de l'ensemble de son exécutif
l'interdiction de la double mandat
aurait permis le renouvellement de la
classe politique
je doute car en fait elle a renforcé le
pouvoir de partis politiques qui ont des
les municipales de 2014
favoriser l'implantation locale d'hommes
et de femmes du sérail cette
interdiction aussi renforcer la
démocratie nous disait tôt c'est oublier
qu'un électeur reste toujours libre de
son vote et du choix de son candidat et
c'est oublier que très souvent des
citoyens dont le maire était
parlementaire leur conduisait dans sa
fonction de maire parce qu'il
considérait que ça vont forcer son
efficacité et servez la commune on nous
a dit que nous on nous dit que le
parlementaire garde un lien avec le
terrain et qu'il n'a rien à hors sol
puisqu'il peut toujours exercer amanda
délibérative de conseiller mes chers
collègues qui ici peut nous faire croire
que la fréquentation assidue efforts
louables des inaugurations suffit à
conférer la connaissance de la gestion
des collectivités
qui ici
qui ici qui ici peut affirmer qu amanda
délibérative est comparable à une
fonction d'exécutive l'interdiction at
elle servi l'efficacité l'intelligence
de la loi et de l'action publique je le
dis clairement non car qui n'entend pas
régulièrement de la part de nos
concitoyens mais aussi des élus que les
lois sont trop souvent hors sol sans
doute généreuse dans l'idée mais parfois
âpre est impossible à mettre en oeuvre
et le sénat se caractérise encore
aujourd'hui par l'expérience d'exécutive
de beaucoup de sénateurs qui permette
d'un futé d'enrichir et de perfectionner
des lois trop souvent dépourvus d'étude
d'impact de près à la mégère collègues
le groupe us et soutiendra non seulement
parce que c'est la proposition de son
président mais avec forte conviction
cette proposition de loi parce qu'elle
est pertinent de l'évaluation des effets
d'une loi censée restaurer la confiance
dans la démocratie mais qui n'a pas tenu
ses promesses elle est pertinente car
elle est mesuré et acceptable est
comprise par l'opinion publique
contrairement à ce que j'entends ici ou
là d'aucuns la trouve inacceptable et
d'autres trop restic très strictes x est
sans doute la preuve qu'elle est
extrêmement mesurer parce qu'elle est
justement calibré avec le recours à un
seuil je ne suis pas une fan des seuils
qui sont toujours comment dire
frustrant voir castrateur mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce seuil est nécessaire
et satisfaisant parce qu'il tire singes
mans les leçons de critiques qui ont
parfois été faite aux élus parfois sans
doute justifiée mais aussi savamment et
démagogiquement amplifiée par l'effet
relents apporte du populisme osant par
cette proposition de loi réaffirmer la
valeur de l'engagement des élus qui sont
les essentiels de la république et d'une
démocratie où chaque citoyen peut
librement devenir lui aussi un élu de la
république
inferno clairement que si les élus sont
naturellement soumis aux lois de la
république nous refusons l'éternel
suspicion et le procès en culpabilité
qui est le poison du populisme et de la
démogagie de la démagogie et qui menace
bien plus que nos petits personnes notre
démocratie nous regagnerons la confiance
de nos concitoyens par l'efficacité de
l'action publique et c'est la seule
manière de le faire et cette proposition
de loi y contribuer avec raison et
sagesse le groupe uc votre à bientôt
cette proposition votera certainement ce
proposition noah et je vous invite tous
à réfléchir le madame la ministre je
vous invite à porter au président de la
république qui réfléchit à des nécessité
d' évolution cette excellente
proposition du sénat qui doit aller au
delà d'un simple débat entre nous je
vous remercie le cumul des mandats est
l'une des nombreuses victimes de la
démagogie son interdiction en 2014 sous
le quinquennat socialiste a été obtenue
en cédant tu as une petite musique
simple et facile les cumulards sont
d'offres profiteurs jouer sur l'air de
les politiques tous des pourris
nous savons bien au sein de la chambre
des territoires que la réalité est
beaucoup plus complexe
nous avons presque tous exercé des
mandats locaux avant notre mandat
parlementaire 1 nous savons à quel point
ces fonctions peuvent permettre aux
parlementaires d'être connecté au
terrain de comprendre en profondeur la
réalité vécue par les élus locaux et nos
concitoyens nous savons aussi que tous
les cumuls ne sont pas logés à la même
enseigne il est insupportable aux yeux
de certains que les parlementaires
puissent exercer leur mandat une
fonction pendant leur mandat une
fonction exécutive au sein des
collectivités tauriac territoriale
fussent une commune de moins de 100
habitants
mais il est apparemment parfaitement
normal que le cumul soit possible entre
les différentes responsabilités et
président ce local les positions
dogmatiques leçon souvent préjudiciables
réalité du terrain cela explique
peut-être pourquoi l' enquête réalisée à
la demande des auteurs de la proposition
de loi laisse apparaître que 54% des
sondés se disent favorables au cumul des
mandats telle qu'envisagée par le texte
il est cependant peu probable que les
soldats y compris que les communes de
moins de 10000 habitants représente en
réalité la quasi totalité des communes
de france 3-2 cela a été dit tout à
l'heure et 97% il est de même assez peu
probable que le score de 54 % en faveur
du cumul soit identique à présent que le
en cumul des indemnités doit être
abandonnée quand bien même elles sont
décrétés c'était constitutionnellement
nécessaire mais ce non cumul
d'indemnités était lui politiquement
indispensable sur le terrain beaucoup
d'élus locaux regrettent à
l'interdiction du cumul d'autres y sont
fortement attachés il est bien difficile
de déterminer avec précision les effets
réels qu'entraîne de son interdiction
sur notre démocratie
certains parmi nous ont rappelé que
l'interdiction votée en 2014 l'avait été
à la suite d' enquêtes d'opinion à cet
égard plusieurs exemples sont venus
enrichir ces dernières années une
sagesse populaire et qu'il nous faut
faire un autre surtout en cette période
sont d'agir souvent sondage varie bien
fol qui s'y fie en fait la question se
pose de savoir s'il est opportun de
changer les règles quatre ans après
qu'elles sont entrées en vigueur bien
sûr un lit en plus étroitement les
collectivités territoriales avec le
parlement le cumul des mandats pourrait
permettre de renforcer l'ancrage
territorial des parlementaires certains
cumulent ont effectivement nourrit des
mandats parlementaires tandis que
d'autres cumulent n'ont pas apporté
grand chose en l'état actuel du droit
les parlementaires avaient déjà exercé
un mandat dans un exécutif local sans
tomber sous le coup de l'interdiction du
cumul un tel mandat donne lui aussi
accès à la réalité que vivent nos
collectivités mais ce n'est probablement
pas suffisant nous comprenons le sens de
la proposition de loi
maintenir vivant le lien entre les
français et leurs élus
c'est un sujet qui doit tous nous
préoccupe et au delà de la question du
cumul se trouve celle de l'engagement de
chaque élu celle aussi de la place que
nous accordons à l'élu aux scènes de la
république et du statut que nous voulons
lui donner
les parlementaires doivent pouvoir
remplir au mieux leur mission de
représentation de nos concitoyens dans
la lutte contre cette déconnexion et au
delà des idées préconçues il faut
reconnaître qu'il existe des arguments
favorables mais aussi défavorable au
coup il demanda toutefois sur ce sujet
les membres de notre groupe photo roche
chacun en fonction de leurs convictions
à l'article 1er
un ordre trois amendements identiques de
suppression l'amendement numéro un
monsieur qu'est rochât
merci madame la présidente cet
amendement constitue forcément le
dispositif central de l'as de la loi
puisqu'il ne il est le seul à il est le
seul à demeurer
l'opposition nous l'avons vu dans les
discussions que nous venons d'avoir il y
avait une opposition forte de
philosophie d'un côté ceux qui ont
déposé cette loi et qui considèrent que
leur tour un cumul même tempéré du cumul
des mandats serait une nécessité et un
retour entre guillemets à la normale et
nous qui considérons que ce n'est pas un
retour à la normale mais plutôt un
retour à une pathologie qu'il vaut mieux
éviter
les arguments qui sont ceux qui ont été
développés de la déconnexion ne nous
semble absolument pas pertinent dans
l'ensemble des démocraties occidentales
qu'il s'agisse de
l'état unitaire ou d'états fédéraux pour
que les choses soient claires le cumul
ou est une acception où n'existe pas et
nous considérons que ce chemin doit
continuer à être celui que nous
empruntons tout simplement pour bien
séparer un monde local du monde
parlementaire et en ne faisant pas
croire qu'il est nécessaire d'appartenir
aux 2 pourrait bien faire et bien faire
fonctionner ensemble
merci la maman numéro 4 monsieur masson
oui je voudrais répondre d'abord madame
le ministre qui
disait que mon précédent amendement
viser une disposition qui était de
l'ordre de la loi et pas de la loi
organique j'aurais simplement lui dire
que si elle avait été complète et
juridiques en fait ça avait été votée
comme une loi organique c'était une loi
organique a été voté et c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui a déclassé le
caractère organique de loi une fois
qu'elle était votée bien après il ya eu
qui a déclaré que cette loi était du
fait que cette loi qui avait été voté
comme loi organique était une war
ordinaire et c'est pour ça que ça se
retrouve en loi ordinaire donc si mon
amendement avait été votée est bien le
roi libre concert au tissu
constitutionnel de faire la même chose
et de d'aligner la disposition sur la
loi ordinaire alors je crois que madame
le ministre il faut faut bien regarder
l'historique quand on fait des
affirmations il faut bien regarder
l'historique et pour pas se tromper
voilà ceci étant bien j'ai largement
défendu mon opposition voulait tous
compris que j'étais opposé ou à la
proposition de loin et donc vous
comprendrez mais je pourrais encore
remettent une couche mais le et donc
vous comprendrez que je suis pour la
suppression de cet article
merci la maman 22 monsieur benarroch
c'est un nous surprendra pas c'est
encore un amendement de suppression de
cet article bien entendu puisque notre
groupe est opposé à vous le savez vous
l'avez compris à la pratique ancienne du
cumul des mandats j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure pour nous le cumul bloc le
renouvellement de la représentation
témoigne d'une conception de la
politique et du politique dont
l'objectif principal est de concentrer
le maximum de pouvoir entre nombre
restreint de décideurs le non cumul
permet par contre d'accroître le nombre
de personnes en responsabilité de
renforcer la vitalité de la démocratie
la diversité de la représentation
politique et la confiance des citoyens
les parlementaires ne nous semble pas
avoir besoin au cumul des
responsabilités au sein des exécutifs
des collectivités pour s'engager
pleinement dans la vie politique locale
de leur circonscription chacun d'entre
nous en est l'exemple et pour conserver
une proximité avec le terrain et y mener
des actions cela fait partie intégrante
de nos missions et nous les menons à
bien quotidiennement par conséquent les
auteurs du groupe écologie solidarité
territoire du présente à mende mode de
mode la suppression de l'article 1er
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur oui madame la présidente
sa mouche surprendra pas ceux ne
surprendra pas je serais défavorable à
l'ensemble de ces trois 3 amendements de
suppression forcément puisque on vide de
son contenu
cette ppl haut je voudrais quand même
rappeler que je pense que la crise de
défiance
entre le politique et nos concitoyens
n'est pas exclusivement lié certes au
cumul des mandats l'affaiblissement du
parlement
il ya plusieurs causes on pourra parler
on en parlera d'ailleurs
prochainement de des ordonnances et la
prolifération des ordonnances on peut
également parler du septennat au
quinquennat je peux être d'accord avec
vous mais force est de constater quand
même par expérience que quand un texte
arrive de l'assemblée nationale
je prends le texte climat et résilience
il y avait une disposition
rappelez vous un amendement déposé par
un parlementaire qui n'a jamais exercé
de mandat local et qui est imposée au
flot de véhicules des communes d'être
100% propre à partir de 2025 pour
s'aligner avec le privé nous sommes tous
opposés parce que nous avons également
une expérience en tant que élu local et
surtout de l'ancienneté en tant que
maires ou présidents de département et
donc vous voyez l'utilité quand même
d'exercer un moment donné une fonction
exécutif afin d'éviter ces écueils là en
matière législative c'est la raison pour
laquelle je serais défavorable aux trois
amendements
[Musique]
ministre
le gouvernement est favorable à ces
amendements puisque nous sommes en
cohérence avec la position que nous
avons sur le texte c'est-à-dire un avis
défavorable et la suppression de cet
article vise tout simplement faire
tomber l'article est donc à faire tomber
la proposition de loi
merci alors monsieur kerrouche
indication de date oui on réagit sans
justo aux propos de monsieur le
rapporteur et en le faisant
respectueusement je pense qu'il faut
faire attention à ce qu'on dit aussi
il n'ya pas de prérequis en france qui
conditionne le fait que pour être
parlementaire il faut avoir été élu
local il faut faire attention parce que
mais je pense que ce n'était pas votre
attention ça voudrait dire que les élus
de la république en marche que comme
vous savez je n'ai pas l'habitude de
défendre je pense que tout le monde l'a
constaté
était ou serait illégitime parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas élus locaux et je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à la façon
dont on formule les observations on peut
imaginer on peut imaginer aussi que le
fait d'avoir une expérience ne se réduit
pas dans la vie à une expérience d'élu
même si elle est importante le fait
d'être parlementaire c'est aussi ce
qu'on apporte en tant qu'individu par
son expérience professionnelle par la
trajectoire de vie particulières que
l'on a eu donc ces élus sont légitimes
pour autant on peut
imaginez que sur certains domaines il
est préférable d'avoir une expérience
locale encore une fois ce n'est même pas
en cause la légitimité qui est la leur
croire que celle ci est indispensable et
serait la seule façon pour que l'on
puisse fonctionner je pense que c'est
faux également on peut tout à fait être
au courant de ce qui se passe localement
sans être élu local et je le répète on a
beau avoir une histoire de kull
extrêmement importante en france il n'en
demeure pas moins que dans les
démocraties occidentales
cette anomalie n'existe pas ça n'empêche
pas les élus d'être connecté alors on
peut dire que nous somme exceptionnelle
en tous points mais on peut aussi
considérer que nous sommes atypiques sur
ce point en particulier
donc il nous semble inutile de revenir
sur cette loi d'autant que et j'y
reviendrai après dès que cette porte est
ouverte on voit bien avec l'amendement
qui suit le sous-amendement de madame
d'appel que d'autres ports doivent
s'ouvrir parce que cette mesure
spécifique ne suffit pas mais
alors même un pressing et elle
ne serait pas une surprise moi je suis
en profond désaccord avec nos collègues
parce que je pense que pendant le débat
où on a déplacé le débat sur la question
existentielle est très vrai de ce qu'est
devenu le parlement aujourd'hui pour
d'autres raisons la proposition de loi
qui est fait et l'opposition à
l'amendement de monsieur qu'est rouge
c'est du fait qu'il ne s'agit pas
forcément de lire simplement ce texte
comme permettant un parlementaire de
cumul est qu un mandat local il s'agit
aussi de permettre un maire d'une
commune de 500 habitants de devenir s'il
le veut librement et personne ne
l'imposent à qui que ce soit
parlementaire il n'ya pas d'exigence à
ce qu'un parlementaire et à mandat
d'exécutif local je dis simplement que
moi je pense que la démocratie elle est
tellement forte et elle est tellement
que les électeurs sont capables en leur
âme et conscience de savoir si leur
député maire et efficace et 6 vols de ce
candidat ou d'un autre et que moi je
n'attaque personne en île en
illégitimité
s'il n'a pas de demande à bras et que
sincèrement je pense que très souvent
ici on reproche de ne pas faire
d'évaluation de l'efficacité d'une loi
chère collègue éric kerrouche cette loi
de 2014 qui est annoncé comme gary
chauvin n'a rien guéri parce que les
parlementaires ne sont pas contents les
élus locaux ne le sont pas on n'a pas
retrouvé la confiance des électeurs et
on est toujours autant d'abstention moi
je suis favorable à un nombre de mandats
limités dans le temps je pense que ça
c'est plus favorable à cette vision que
vous avez qui est un enfermement dans
une doctrine qui était celle de 2014 et
vous n'avez rien de moderne en cela mon
cher collègue merci s'est prise dans
l'anjou
je suis un peu étonné parce que j'ai
entendu à plusieurs reprises que cette
proposition de loi relevait de certaines
anomalies mais être parlementaire et
membre d'un conseil régional depuis
trois millions d'habitants c'est pas une
anomalie et vous pouvez pas être maire
d'une commune de 50 habitants je pense
que vraiment il ya un vrai il ya un vrai
souci à ce niveau-là et puis aussi sur
le sujet il est pour moi difficile
d'accepter d'entendre qu'il suffit de
n'avoir qu'un mandat
pour avoir de la proximité
et bien si c'était vrai
on n'entendrait pas et je vois peut-être
pas mêmes et les goûts c'est
certainement pour ça on n'entendrait pas
de la part de certains élus nous dit ah
mais attendez mais qu'est-ce que vous
êtes allés voter qu'est-ce que vous êtes
allés voter sur ce sujet parce qu'on
bien dessus combien de votes on met
combien de lois on défend et qui
effectivement ne correspondent pas du
tout à l'atteinte de nos concitoyens est
sûre sur le sur le problème de la
proximité sur la problème à proximité
quand vous rencontrez un maire
qui vous explique un certain nombre de
choses vous pouvez comprendre ce qui
vous dit vous pouvez partager ce qui
vous dit mais il ya une chose que l'on
ne peut que l'on ne fait pas c'est qu'on
ne vit pas au quotidien ce cas les
difficultés qu un maire je pense que ce
serait bien effectivement quoi ils
réfléchissent et qu'on regarde comment
on peut faire pour enlever cette
anomalie qui vient effectivement
n'accumule et comme l'a dit un des
orateurs tout à l'heure on passe on
passe de 104 360° à zéro degré on est
passé on pouvait être maire de paris
député président de la région ile de
france et aujourd'hui on ne pourrait
plus être
sénateur et maire d'une commune de 90
habitants 200 habitants je pense qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on y réfléchisse et le
bon sens paysan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du débat je ne résiste pas à la
tentation de d'interpeller nos collègues
socialistes et singulièrement notre legs
et rouge parce qu'au fond j'aimerais
comprendre la philosophie de ce qui a
prévalu à ce que c'est toi sur le cumul
soit tranchée de la sorte soit vous
prenez comme juge de paix la quantité de
travail on peut l'entendre mais alors je
vais fermer les arguments développés par
notre collègue le président l'on joue à
l'instant vous avez fait d'immenses
régions vous permettez aujourd'hui un
élu un parlementaire d'être conseiller
régional président de commission et vous
interdire y ait dans le même temps un
maire d'une commune rurale de 50
habitants d'être parlementaire
vous avez parlé dans votre discussion
monsieur qui rouge de pathologies
d'anomalies alors aller jusqu'au bout
pourquoi ne vous avez vous pas imposé
n'avez-vous pas imposer le cumul strict
d'être simplement député ou sénateur il
ya un moment donné vous avez fait de
l'eau tiède il ya un moment donné ou de
philosophie où vous l explication ne
tient pas tout simplement parce que vous
avez été à la moitié du sujet vous
n'avez pas osé aller au bout sûrement
par clientélisme parce que vous n'avez
absolument pas traité la question la
question du cumul horizontale la réalité
elle est là alors souffre et souffre et
souffrait monsieur kerrouche à un moment
donné que l'on puisse s'interroger sur
les motivations aujourd'hui qui vous
permettent de mettre le critère où vous
le mettez est considéré qu'à un moment
donné on peut oui être maire d'une
commune de 50 habitants là où on peut
être dans un temps conseiller régional
voir exercer une présidence de
commission dans un grand conseil
régional voilà mais c'est ici
merci madame la présidente madame lamine
ba dans la ministre oui mes chers
collègues je suis étonné des mois contre
des mots qu'on emploie on parle du non
cumul des mandats mais en fait on peut
tout à fait être sénateur et s'était dit
à maintes reprises et conseiller
municipal et conseiller départemental et
conseiller régional rien et je doute pas
de votre sincérité chers collègues de
droite je ne doute pas de votre
sincérité
d'avoir envie de participer à la vie
locale d'autres pays bien évidemment
mais vous pouvez travailler dans des
commissions départementales municipales
régionales
je suis conseiller municipal de base en
guinée
rien ne m'interdit de siéger au syndicat
d'énergie rien ne m'interdit s'agit au
scot rien ne m'interdit à siéger sur les
réflexions de l'urbanisme rien il ya une
seule chose nous est interdit d'entrer
dans le cadre de la loi c'est le non
cumul de l'exécutif donc c'est en fait
c'est le pouvoir ou ne voulait pas
partager c'est ça est-ce qu'on peut tout
à fait on peut tout à fait on peut tout
à fait faire confiance à quelqu'un
d'autre de notre sensibilité d'un autre
même sensibilité politique d'avoir on va
dire un ami
que vous pouvez conseillez et de la même
manière que si vous étiez là chef de
l'exécutif en fait c'est une vision un
peu rétro rennes que vous avez delà de
la gestion de la collectivité on essaie
voilà donc moi je crois à votre
sincérité de vouloir participer à la
gestion quotidienne d'un territoire
c'est mon cas c'est celle qu'a quasiment
de tous les gens qui sont ici sauf que
il faut accepter de 2-2-2 de laisser
exécutif la présidence d'un glyphe que
soient maires etc seydoux président de
département ou de région sait c'est que
ça finalement
merci monsieur fiel r
oui madame la présidente des ministres
moi je voudrais apporter le témoignage
d'un parlementaire hors sol puisque
depuis un an je ne cumule plus de
demandes à j'ai laissé mes mandats alors
que après 25 ans maire d'une commune 20
ans président d'une intercommunale
impression d'être complètement
déconnecté et de pas avoir pertinence
dans mes interventions
et gg
j'ai eu une conversation avec un député
qui m'expliquait depuis qu'il était plus
maire de sa commune il en était
complètement déconnectés du terrain
voilà c'est sa femme qui était maire
maintenant et lui les premiers adjoints
alors je sais pas lequel des deux est le
plus déconnectés de la réalité
elle plus hors sol des élus moi il y a
un peu plus loin on était en campagne
pour ces élections sénatoriales et on a
rencontré des maires mais on a aussi
rencontré des grands électeurs qui ne
sont pas et moi je trouve que dans les
discours que l'on tient aujourd'hui
c'est un manque de respect vis-à-vis
d'élus de basques qui ne sont pas mère
mais qui sont impliqués dans leur
collectivité et qui savent ce qui s'y
passe moi je depuis que j'ai laissé la
place j'assiste aux conseils municipaux
de ma commune mais même d'autres au
conseil communautaire de mon territoire
mais même d'autres pour savoir pour ne
pas être simplement le lobbyiste d'un
terrain dans cette assemblée parce que
c'est ce qu'on a entendu ce qu on entend
certains voudraient que leurs mères
continuent à être parlementaire pour
pouvoir bien faire du lobby pour leur
territoire moi je crois qu on a un
combat à mener c'est de revaloriser
l'ensemble des élus municipaux et même
ceux qui n'ont pas de fonctions
exécutives
ça c'est un vrai combat et le deuxième
c'est de consacrer notre temps et notre
énergie à revaloriser le travail
parlementaire et le rôle des
parlementaires voilà ce que voulait dire
un parlementaire hors sol
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix donc
ces amendements identiques
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe socialiste
écologiste et et républicains donc les
amendements 1,4 et 22 je vous rappelle
que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable et l'avis du gouvernement
est favorable il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert tout personne ne
demande à voter donc le scrutin est clos
alors voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 5 16 amendements identiques
numéro 1 4 et 22 contenu de l'ensemble
des délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 329 nombre de suffrages exprimés
321 pour l'adoption 120 contre 201 le
sénat n'a pas adopté
alors 5 un moment faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
d'amendements numéro 20 de monsieur paco
qui voit un sous-amendement m gatel
messieurs paco
merci madame la présidente
dames 1 min ce cher collègue mon
amendement vient compléter la
proposition pertinente de notre ami
marseille
notre ami marseille a souhaité donc
assouplir la règle sur le cumul des
mandats
en permettant l'intégration la direction
d'un exécutif municipal par un
parlementaire
ça me semble une mesure particulièrement
pertinente je vous propose d'aller un
peu plus loin en permettant à un
parlementaire de devenir aussi ou de
redevenir aussi
vice-président d'un département ou d'une
région
alors quelle est la situation actuelle
la loi nous a permis effectivement
de sortir des abus d'hier
j'ai dans mon département j'ai eu un un
sénateur de gauche
qui a cumulé jusqu'à 17 fonction il y
avait eu droit au canard enchaîné juste
avant donc que la loi soit votée alors
évidemment les cumuls de part et d'autre
on le sait très bien toujours est il que
ces situations étaient inacceptables
néanmoins aujourd'hui quelle est la
réalité la situation la réalité c'est
que lorsque vous êtes conseiller
municipal départemental ou régional vous
avez un conseil municipal par mois ou
tous les deux mois ou tous les trois
mois un une commission permanente et
donc en fait la prédiction c'est de
savoir quel est l'intérêt des
collectivités est ce qu'elles doivent se
passer de l'expérience du savoir faire
nos parlementaires je ne le pense pas et
pour terminer mon petit propos je veux
rappeler les propos d'un éminent
prédécesseur ici il fut député maire
sénateur maire premier ministre maire de
lille
pour notre entente est il avait je
termine ma phrase il avait une belle
expression pour montrer l'importance du
mandat local pour le parlementaire il
disait que c'était une courroie
d'enracinement donc on ne tombe pas dans
les travers d'hier mais on essaye quand
même de
la force du parlement à nos collègues
email si chers collègues
même gatel pour le sous-amendement
en talents nous partons de la
proposition raisonnée et raisonnable du
président marseille qui je rappelle a
recueilli dans la dans le sondage qui a
été fait à une majorité d'avis
favorables de la part de nos concitoyens
je rappelle qu'il s'agit pas simplement
de permettre un parlementaire de cumuler
mais à un maire de pouvoir aussi être
parlementaire et donc j'entends bien
l'amendement qui est proposée par notre
collègue paco toutefois
le sila moment de notre collègue paco
est acceptée
je présenterai un sous-amendement parce
que partant de la dimension raisonnable
que propose le président marseille à
savoir une collectivité ou 1,1 pc de
10000 habitants ou moins il me semble
nécessaire de permettre un parlementaire
qui pourrait être maire d'une commune de
moins de 10000 habitants où mr du code
et l'idée d'une commune nouvelle il me
semble cohérent et légitime de permettre
qu'ils puissent être aussi s'il le veut
s'il est élu par ses compères si je puis
dire d'être président d'un ep six de
moins de 10000 habitants il en existe
près de 300 en france je vous rappelle
que la loi notre a fixé un seuil à 15000
habitants
mais ce seuil était tellement on va dire
théorie que il y a eu un certain nombre
d'exceptions pour prendre en compte les
territoires qui ont une densité
démographique très faible des
territoires de montagne ou des
territoires insulaires
merci l'amendement numéro 6 monsieur
masson
avait masque sur le nez monsieur masson
mais je vais pas vous le répéter toute
la soirée un merci
mon amendement numéro 6 reprend
d'ailleurs certains abonnements qu'on a
déjà évoqué et pour ma part je voudrais
dire que les deux amendements qui
viennent d'être évoqués avant les miens
avant cet amendement numéro 6 conforte
ce que je pensais ce que je disais c'est
le la proposition de loi c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt et tout le monde est
prêt à s'engouffrer derrière l'arbre qui
cache la forêt pour rajouter encore des
des amputations à la loi pour amputer
encore plus la loi contre les cumuls moi
je pense que disons dans cette affaire
là on a on a à l'évidence le fait que
tout le monde voudrait bien veut pas
tout le monde mais tous ceux qui
soutiennent cette profession de loin
vous très bien revenir au système ancien
ou disons il y avait 10 super cumul et
moi je vais dire nous dire nous
expliquer que s'il n'y avait pas la loi
sur les cumuls et bien les le sénat
saurait mieux ce qu'il faut faire et se
battre et un petit peu mieux pour
répondre aux aspirations des gens moi je
vais vous dire avant 2017 1 il n'y avait
pas il n'y avait pas d'interdiction de
cumul de fonctions locales et c'est
cultiver locale n'empêche la loi notre
elle a été votée par le sénat alors il
nous avons été à peu près une centaine
sur l'ensemble des sénateurs à voter
contre jusqu'au bout et ceux ci ont voté
contre ce n'était pas obligatoirement
les gens qui étaient le plus en cumul de
man qui était le plus tôt en dehors des
cumuls de mandats exécutifs et ça ça
prouve bel et bien que disons c'est un
faux argument de d'expliquer que disons
ceux qui n'ont pas de mandat local
ne connaissent pas du tout les problèmes
monsieur masson vous avez l'amendement
numéro 5 le numéro 14 est le numéro 8
pour avoir ensuite de l'avis de la
commission sur l'ensemble vous avez la
parole sont défendus
d'accord on va considérer s'est défendu
parce que vous allez encore me reproche
à me reprocher mon match me descend en
bas du nez alors quand vous persécutent
et moi j'arrête
très bien merci beaucoup l'avis de la
commission sur un portable
merci madame la présidente alors
effectivement le notre collègue
paco
nous propose d'aller plus loin dans
cette proposition de loin puisqu'il il
entend lever l'incompatibilité du mandat
de député ou de sénateur avec des
fonctions d'adjoint au maire de
vice-président de l'assemblée des bancs
d'une collectivité territoriale de
membres du bureau de l'assemblée des
français de l'étranger et de président
d'un conseil consulaire si c'est bien ça
et donc
on va émettre un avis de sagesse tout
simplement parce que effectivement ça
perturbe les équilibres du texte
proposé par le président marseille même
si la demande est pleinement légitime
pour les communes de plus de 10 mille
habitants j'entends bien j'avais oublié
cette précision qui me paraît importante
et sur le sous-amendement de françoise
gatel je partage pleinement son avis est
là avec beaucoup plus d'engouement si
j'ose dire puisqu'on est dans la dans la
lignée du texte puisqu'on on reste en
dessous des moins de dix mille c'est un
avis de sagesse voilà
un parterre demander pardon j'avais
oublié je demande quand même à vis de
sagesse avec une condition pour notre
collègue paco par cohérence de retirer
donc au neuvième alinéa les fonctions de
président et de membre de gouvernement
puisque ça n'a rien à voir par rapport à
la philosophie de l'amendement défendu
monsieur pas qu'on vous êtes d'accord
donc cesser rectifié donc il sera enlevé
donc aux 9 et de membres du gouvernement
en revanche maintenant il faut donner la
vie sur les amendements de monsieur
masson soriano ça n'étonnera personne
j'ai un avis défavorable sur les
amendements de monsieur masson merci la
vie du gouvernement madame la ministre
alors ça sera un avis défavorable sur
l'ensemble des amendements le régime
issu de la loi de 2014 vise l'ensemble
des fonctions exécutives or les
fonctions de vice-président font partie
intégrante des fonctions exécutives
exercé au sein des opci et par ailleurs
si le régime des incompatibilités
prévues par le code électoral fait
obstacle à ce qu'un député ou sénateur
exercent des fonctions exécutives
locales d'une collectivité territoriale
ou d'un opci il n'exclut pas la
possibilité pour ces mêmes élus de
disposer d'un mandat local au sein des
assemblées délibérantes des
collectivités ou des établissements
publics en question un député et un
sénateur peut ainsi par exemple
parfaitement occupé un siège de
conseiller municipal ou de conseiller
départemental et j'entends évidemment
votre allusion monsieur le sénateur paco
a regretté pierre mauroy mais je ne
crois pas que vous soyez aussi sur la
même longueur d'onde sur
sa dernière phase et une de ses
dernières expressions qui disait que
face au chômage la solution de sagesse
et que les travailleurs travaillent
moins
si monsieur kerrouche pour explication
de vote s'il vous
oui plusieurs plusieurs plusieurs points
d'abord pour répondre à à la présidente
françoise gatel les français sont pour
le cumul non non chers françoise ils
sont contre le cumul et il y à un
sondage que vous avez pré cités avec une
formulation qui est très particulière
qui fait que dans ce sondage eh bien ils
seraient pour mais dans le temps ils
sont contrés de manière structurelle si
on confond les sondages et les votations
au vu des sondages à la présidentielle
nous sommes tous très malheureux ce soir
deuxième point s'agissant des
dérogations pour la loi nôtre en terme
de densité il n'y a pas que la loi notre
toutes les lois sur l'intercommunalité
avant avait prévu des procédures des
règles dérogatoires pour les procédures
peu denses
à mon excellent à mon excellent collègue
mathieu darnaud qui affirment les choses
facilement
moi je suis d'accord avec lui on devrait
aller plus loin mais je vais juste lui
rappeler quelque chose en 1985 c'est la
gauche qui interdit les super cumul
parce qu'il y en avait trop en 2000 il
faut revenir à la table parce
qu'effectivement il ya des stratégies
d'évitement qui ont été mises en place
et je vous rappelle que d'une part la
loi de 2000 durci les conditions du
cumul mais que d'autre part elle
interdit aussi des pratiques qui s'était
développé à l'époque comme les pratiques
de tirer les listes ans dans les élus en
tête de liste étant des locomotives qui
se démettait après de leur mandat donc à
chaque fois on voit bien qu'il faut
revenir de manière itérative pour lutter
contre le cumul des mandats et j'entends
mathieu d'ardon et que a priori il
faudrait aller plus loin dont acte vous
êtes majoritaires dans cette assemblée
j'attends bien sûr vos initiatives en la
matière plus fondamentalement sur les
amendements qui sont proposés on voit
très bien où on en est bien entendu
compte au fixe un seuil où il dit elle
ne convient à personne et on a toujours
des bonnes raisons de rajouter des
conditions qui serait dérogatoire pour
faire en sorte que et ça ne fonctionne
pas on ouvre la boîte de pandore alors
je vais être simple et finir par cette
fois qu'on crie reconnaît c'est ce que
j'allais faire madame la présidente au
fond de la boîte de pandore y rester une
chose l'espoir est bien nous nous avons
l'espoir d'une démocratie qui soit
marquée par le non cumul et le reste est
de deux parallèles mais le mandat
parlementaire le mandat d'élu local mais
oui je me suis pas kossi donc voilà je
fais un équilibre quand même et la prese
et la présidence décide sinon je
rappelle quand même que ces deux minutes
maintenant les interventions et la
présidente gatel c'est à vous pour
deux minutes 2 parce qu'il faut être
oecuméniques monsieur masson
avoué qu'il vaut mieux elle claire sur
des explications quand on dit que ici il
y à des sénateurs qui ont voté la non la
loisne moi je les voter non pas par
conviction mais pour empêcher le pire si
ta version ne vais pas voter ici le
seuil de l'interco n'aurait pas été à
15me les plus graves nous aurions eu par
l'assemblée nationale
le scrutin universel direct pour les
conseillers communautaires donc moi
j'assume mon rôle de digues monsieur
masson disons le voilà deuxièmement
deuxièmement mon cher collègue éric mais
moi je suis ravie je suis heureuse gros
moments que nous passons ensemble et je
vais pas tarder à vous remercier est ce
que vous êtes sur un aveu de culpabilité
en dix ans mais si mme ici en essayant
en essayant de dire que c'est pas la loi
note qui introduit des seuils absolument
étrange mais c'était bien avant alors
que vous êtes bien insister là dessus et
deuxièmement encore une fois mon cher
collègue la seule chose qui m'intéresse
c'est la preuve de l'efficacité
si la loi que vous défendez et je
respecte avec autant de conviction avait
marché ça se saurait c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on aurait une démocratie
où tout le monde serait content serai
heureux il y aurait des femmes il y
aurait des ouvriers y aura toute sorte
de père mais y aurait sans doute aussi
des maires de communes de 50 habitants
qui pour exprimer leur envie d'être
parlementaire et des électeurs à qui on
offrirait le droit de choisir leur
candidat
je me suis prise dans d'arnaud
[Applaudissements]
oui je pars à longer le débat à la
présidente mais je ne résiste pas à
répondre en complément deux excellentes
collègues présidente françoise gatel à
dire qu'on a aussi voté des minorités de
blocage et qu'on a évité la disparition
des départements en faisant oeuvre utile
simplement j'entends ce que dit mon
collègue éric kerrouche mais alors
pourquoi à chaque fois qu'on m'a
souhaité permet d'enraciner un peu plus
les parlementaires dans la vie locale je
pense notamment à tous les amendements
qu'on avait déposé sur les commissions d
e tr sur tous les sujets qui font que le
parlementaire qu'il soit sénateurs ou
députés puissent être un acteur on
plaint de la vie locale à chaque fois à
chaque fois d'un revers de manche vous
avait balayé tous ces sujets enfin je
voudrais dire un autre collègue tissot
qu'on a parfois le sentiment quand on
les écoute que l'exécutif se serait
assimilé les élus de petites communes de
communes de 50 cents habitants à des
élus qui seraient assoiffés de pouvoir
dès lors qu'il intégrera un exécutif je
pense qu'il faut quand même garder
raison les amis parce qu'à un moment
donné moi je veux bien je veux bien tout
mais on a vraiment le sentiment que être
membre d'un exécutif dès lors qu'on est
parlementaire ça serait la pire des
choses et qu'on ne rentrerez dans un
monde le plus ville donc non à un moment
donné je crois qu'il faut raison garder
et il faut se dire que on peut tout à
fait aujourd'hui alors j'entends ce que
dit eric kerrouche il faut bien toujours
des seuils mais enfin convenez que ça
s'est un peu grossier comme explication
parce que quand on tournait à 10 mille
habitants pardon de le dire et je suis
même pas intéressé ma commune fait douze
mille habitants en voyons donc je prêche
pour ces élus locaux ces parlementaires
qui doivent à mon avis garder un lien de
proximité avec les territoires parce que
françoise gatel l'a dit avec une
justesse absolue si on veut faire oeuvre
utile sur des sujets qui sont notamment
des lois territoriales il faut que les
parlementaires vivent au quotidien les
enjeux qui sont dans les textes de loi
merci monsieur le président en bon état
oui merci madame la présidente ça
réchauffe qu' on est quand même sur un
débat un petit peu surréaliste mais ça
aura quand même permis une chose c'est
de devoir que le gouvernement j'ai
entendu était pour le partage du travail
et donc ça ça me fait plutôt plaisir et
donc j'espère qu'on pourra aller plus
loin est revenu au micro s'il vous plaît
plus loin les ralliements non sur ce cas
sur ce qui a été dit d'abord rappeler
quand même que le seuil il a dix mille
et qu'on parle beaucoup de communes de
50 habitants 200 habitants le seuil que
vous souhaitez maîtriser il y a dix
mille mais au-delà de ça moi ce que
j'entends souvent et ce que j'entends
dans ce que vous dites c'est un peu de
dénigrement par rapport aux petites
communes moi j'ai été maire d'une
commune de 150 habitants fin maintenant
qu'ils ont fait un café de son le
travail d'un maire d'une petite commune
ce n'est pas rien c'est un travail de
tous les jours et de présence locale
parce que quand on a pas d'employé
communal
quand on n'a pas de secrétariat de
mairie qu'on doit faire quasi l'ensemble
des choses qui sont à faire sur place
quand on est appelé en semaine parce
qu'il ya une fuite d'eau c'est un peu
difficile d'être là du mardi au jeudi et
puis surtout franchement franchement moi
quand je me comme je me balade sur mon
territoire je pense que je n'ai jamais
rencontré quelqu'un qui m'a dit mais
mangez moi ça il faut absolument qu'ils
aient des cumulards il faut absolument
cumuler un passé le mot je suis désolé
il faut absolument il faut absolument
cumuler le rôle de mère et de et de
parlementaires j'ai jamais entendu ça
j'ai entendu des problématiques de santé
j'ai entendu des problématiques de
déplacement j'ai entendu des
problématiques
d'alimentation et sur les questions
agricoles mais jamais ça a été une pré
une préoccupation et j'ai franchement
pas l'impression en ayant démissionné de
mon rôle de mère d'avoir le lien avec le
conseil municipal ce que j'ai
effectivement cette possibilité et je
les gardais même dans une commune de 200
habitants le le rôle de conseiller
municipal la proximité le le travail de
terrain il me semble que je les ai
également le bon sens paysan
merci merci je vais mettre aux voix le
sous-amendement
numéro 27 qui a reçu donc un avis de
sagesse de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté je mets au
voile amendement 20 avec un avis de
sagesse un avis défavorable du
gouvernement ainsi sous-amendé qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est donc adopté tous
les autres amendements à l'article 1er
dombes et l'article 1er est ainsi rédigé
alors sur l'intitulé de la proposition
de loi mon numéro 7 monsieur masson
le courage de ses opinions et il faut
appeler un chat un chat à la proposition
de loi je cherche je propose de changer
le type de la proposition de loi en
l'appelant proposition de loi organique
tendant à abroger une pas en partie
l'interdiction de cumul de mandat
parlementaire avec une fonction de maire
ou d'adjoint au maire ça c'est vraiment
ce qu'il y avait dans le test dire qu'on
n'avait pas encore adopté l'amendement
sur les vice présidents de conseils
généraux et régionaux mais c'est
vraiment ma le titre que je propose
appelle un chat un chat et explique très
bien a le mérite d'expliquer très bien
ce qu'est la proposition de loi qu'on
est en train de voter on est en train de
rétablir les cumuls et bien moi je suis
contre le rétablissement des cumuls et
je crois que ce ce texte permettrait à
tous nos concitoyens de bien comprendre
de bien comprendre ce qu'on est en train
de voter aujourd'hui
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur oui avis défavorable
monsieur masson l'a dit il n'est plus en
cohérence le titre avec ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a voté et puis j'aime la
simplicité l'implantation locale des
parlementaires c'est quelque chose de
très concret merci la vie du
gouvernement m
merci je vais donc aux voix l'amendement
numéro 7 qui a reçu un avis défavorable
des commissions du gouvernement qu'est
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient n'est donc pas adoptée je
me trouvais à l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi organique mais avant
je vais donner la parole à monsieur
qu'est rouge qui me l'a demandé
merci madame la présidente
donc il est évident qu'il ya deux
positions qui sont très tranchés de part
et d'autre de l'hémicycle et c'est aussi
ça la démocratie pour répondre à
françoise gatel la question c'était de
nous dire est ce que en fait cette loi
la loi de 2014 est mauvaise il faut la
corriger
ma réponse est toute simple est-ce que
c'était mieux avant
et ma réponse est ma réponse elle est ma
réponse à l'est ma réponse elle est tout
aussi tranchée sur le long terme sur le
long terme le cumul des mandats est en
effet un effet négatif nationalement
tout simplement parce que le cumul n'a
pas été représenté de manière
équivalente sur l'ensemble du territoire
et que certains territoires ont été
privilégiés au détriment d'autres parce
que certains étaient parlementaires et
d'autres pas et que localement et ça a
été prouvé localement le cumul a aussi
séché a aussi par de participer de
d'assécher la démocratie par exemple il
ya une enquête très connu qui montrent
que quand on est élu cumulant il y avait
moins de gens qui se présentent et qui
se présentait en phase donc c'était
quelque chose de négatif globalement et
c'est pour ça que nous disons nous nous
y opposons par ailleurs et là je suis
très étonné il ne faut absolument pas
qu'on explique et je pense que ça n'est
pas sérieux que la crise de la
démocratie en france
résulte de l'absence de cumul des
mandats c'est tu peux être une
discussion que nous pouvons avoir entre
nous si si ça a été dit et répété et c
est rien n'est plus faux rien n'est plus
faux ce sont des considérations d'élus
pour les élus la démocratie se fait
avant tout pour le citoyen le pas pris
merci monsieur le président retailleau
je voudrais simplement au nom de mon
groupe dire les deux raisons pour
lesquelles nous allons voter le texte
proposé par mon collègue hervé marseille
la première raison c'est qu'il s'agit de
dénoncer une formidable hypocrisie
d'abord l'hypocrisie du gouvernement qui
s'opposent avec une régularité presque
métronomique à notre proposition alors
que des ministres cumulent ils
appartiennent à l'exécutif pas d'âme il
cumule
hypocrisie de la situation actuelle
puisque on peut être président dans une
région dans un département d'une grande
commission être autorisés à l'être mais
ne pas être autorisés être vice
président et puis situation aussi
hypocrite lorsque il ya bien entendu de
façon horizontale le cumul d'un certain
nombre de fonctions mais la raison elle
est plus fondamentale est-ce que vous
pensez mes chers collègues que la
démocratie française et est réparé par
ce texte curieusement
je suis arrivé tout à l'heure et
j'entendais le plaidoyer de françoise
gatel et notamment sur la loi nôtre mais
ces deux textes sont arrivés en même
temps et bien pour moi ces deux textes
révèlent et procède d'un esprit de
système ils ont construit une forme de
société de l'éloignement on a cru on
nous a vendu que avec de grandes régions
de grands cantons de grandes
intercommunalités tout allait aller
mieux on a construit l'éloignement mes
chers collègues et quand on n'a longe la
distance entre le lieu on prend la
décision 1 et le citoyen eh bien il ya
une relation inverse entre la distance
et la confiance et la crise de la
démocratie c'est la confiance et de même
lorsqu'on coupe les racines d'un élu
parlementaire nationale canton
désarticule le local avec la nationale
alors là aussi on prend le risque
d'affaiblir la confiance voilà mes chers
collègues la raison pour laquelle nous
voulons introduire un peu plus de
liberté nous voulons simplement que
aujourd'hui on s'abandonne à ce que je
considère des solutions de facilité des
fesses des solutions de démagogie qu'on
a proposé parce que les sondages
évidemment aller dans un sens bien on en
veut la liberté la liberté de choix pour
nos concitoyens que de choisir le mais
si
monsieur masson
[Applaudissements]
ayant participé aux débats il est quand
même normal que je je m'exprime dans
l'explication de vote et je voudrais
dire que que ce que viennent de
d'expliquer notre legs retailleau a une
part de vérité mais il ya aussi une part
négative c'est vrai que la loi la loi
notre a été très mauvaise on a on a
agrandi les choses mais il faut pas voir
là il faut pas voir là la mémoire courte
1,15 à quoi ressemble la loi notre haut
niveau par exemple du découpage des
intercommunalités
ben elle ressemble exactement à ce que
je voulais faire sarkozy qui c'est qu'a
initié le premier les redécoupage des
intercommunalités
autoritaire c'est bien sarkozy qui
est-ce qui s qui est-ce qui a voulu au
départ imposé 15 mille habitants
rappelez vous du projet de loi initial
de sarkozy c'était sarkozy on peut
reprocher à hollande d'avoir fait ce que
sarkozy voulait faire mais je crois
qu'il faut quand même ne pas oublier les
responsabilités des uns et des autres ah
c'est comme quand on nous parle de la
défense de la lutte contre la
criminalité qui c'est qui a diminué dix
mille policiers le nombre des policiers
de 10000 c'est sarkozy donc ce jour est
bien c'est que certains de nos collègues
n'ai pas la mémoire courte
merci monsieur salma
merci madame la présidente mes chers
collègues je ne vais pas faire ni le
bilan de sarkozy ni le bilan de hollande
parce que je pense que on est sur un
sujet un peu plus restreint mais bon ça
cela n'empêche enfin je suis très
surpris par la teneur de certains débats
que l'entente ont dans la bouche de
certains élus lorsqu'il rencontre un
citoyen qui est critique la politique
locale mais ce citoyen s'il avait été
élu local il ne parlerait pas de cette
manière eh bien je pense
qu'effectivement lorsque l'on a été élu
local où on a une toute autre vision de
las de ce qui fait société des
politiques locales et lorsque l'on n'est
favorable au cumul de mandats eh bien on
prive tout un tas de citoyens de cette
possibilité de s'inscrire dans la vie
politique locale et je trouve ça très
regrettable c'est complètement en
contradiction avec ce que nous défendons
tous les jours on dit que l'on à des
citoyens qui s'intéressent peu à la vie
locale eh bien je pense que il faut
qu'il participe davantage et comment
mieux participer qu'en étant élu local
donc effectivement il faut lutter contre
le cumul sans doute que cette loi n'est
pas aboutie et qu'il faut aller plus
loin mais ce n'est surtout pas en ayant
des positions réactionnaires que l'on ne
va arranger le débat démocratique dans
ce pays je pense que vraiment
aujourd'hui et on a besoin de chacun et
de chaque citoyen qui s'investissent
dans la vie locale merci merci je me
suis richard
juin
de longs développements pour
espérer que ce débat se conclut là
nous avons bien des motifs de nous
interroger sur l'état de la démocratie
française et sur la relation des
citoyens avec ce que nous faisons quand
nous pensons les représenter il y a sans
doute beaucoup de questions à se poser
simplement
vraiment vous ne nous avez pas convaincu
que l'idée de rétablir un cumul
partielle de fonction alors que les
outils dont nous disposons
statutairement légalement pour être au
contact des citoyens et les
collectivités dans la proximité existe
déjà il me semble véritablement que
c'est une illusion que que vous
conservez que si nous voulons nous
réinterroger ce sera évidemment pendant
la campagne des élections de 2022 sur ce
qui fait adhésion la démocratie
véritablement ce n'est pas cet
arrangement institutionnel un peu bancal
qui nous aiderait à en sortir est par
conséquent il me semble bien que cette
proposition sera vite oublié
merci monsieur boillon
oui merci madame la présidente
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu que le
président sarkozy avait fait beaucoup de
mauvaises choses une science qui l'avait
proposée qui je crois à l'époque cela
n'avait pas été refusé par beaucoup de
parlementaires
c'était la création du conseiller
territorial
le conseiller territorial qui
l'avait proposé
votre masque sur le nez je vous remercie
le président g conseiller territorial
qui l'avait proposée permet était
effectivement d'avoir des élus qu'ils
puissent siéger dans un conseil
départemental impôts ces régionales or
le découpage qui a été réalisé des
grandes régions telles qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui nous permet
vraisemblablement de plus pour le faire
et ça c'est vraiment dommage parce que
là on avait la possibilité de réduire le
fameux millefeuille dont tout le monde
parle et mais que personne n'a cherché à
réduire je crois que c'était une
solution qui aurait permis non seulement
d'éviter des cumuls mais qui aurait
permis aussi une plus grande proximité
des élus sur le devenir des citoyens
merci alors voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 6 sur l'ensemble du texte et
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 341 nombre de suffrages exprimés
316 pour l'adoption 197 contre 119 le
sénat a adopté
[Musique]